hey guys it is the second of September
today my name is Jess and you're
watching game [ __ ] nice PlayStation has
officially announced the upcoming 3.0
system update for the ps4 and detailed
its new features the update will
increase cloud storage capacity for PS
plus members from one gigabyte to 10
introduced youtube live streaming
capabilities and allow direct sharing of
videos that are up to 10 seconds long
through Twitter the update will also
include a new event hub where you can
check out an overview of what activities
are going on around the games you play
most said activities might include a
double XP weekend or the launch of
seasonal in-game events in the Friends
app you'll now get access to a favorite
groups feature so you can group your
pals and is basically your myspace tub8
all over again the update is also adding
communities which will have access to
their own message board and to be able
to join parties through a communal now
playing area sony has said that those of
you accepted for the beta will be able
to get their hands on the update very
soon Microsoft has stepped out of the
way just in time for machinima to get
slapped with a lawsuit settlement today
the YouTube network will now shell out
for saying positive things about the
xbox one around its launch without
informing users of the Microsoft
sponsorship behind it although it would
appear that Microsoft was very much
involved in the wrong doing here the
Xbox giant are off scot-free while
machinima have opted to settled
regarding the charges against them for
what the federal trade commission called
deceptive marketing machinima paid
youtubers to post positive videos about
the xbox one and some of its launch
games which would normally be fairly
standard practice but they failed to
properly inform audiences of the
sponsorship in another xbox marketing
push machinima pledged to pay popular
youtubers one dollar for every 1,000
views up to the value of 25k without
requiring them to acknowledge the
sponsorships in the video the FTC have
ruled that machinima must to disclose
endorsements
future they also explained that the
fault lies with machinima and not
Microsoft who later release a statement
saying we are pleased that the FTC
recognized microsoft has vigorous
compliance processes and procedures
bull-sponsored campaigns finally Konami
and today Okajima have released a short
documentary in which the veteran
developer discusses the hardships in
creating metal gear solid 5 the phantom
pain some suspect that considering
relations between Kojima and Konami are
fairly sour the so-called debriefing
video is a farewell message but we can't
be sure in the video kajima says my
energy comes from the players my mission
is to exceed their expectations it's all
that matters to me I've been working on
making metal gear solid 5 the best it
can possibly be balancing and tweaking
right up until the very end players will
not be disappointed I'm sorry it took so
long but I feel we've created something
very special and I hope everyone will
enjoy it so watch the video in full head
over to our story on gamespot let me
know down in the comments section what
you think about YouTube sponsorships you
can hedge against but we've got stories
on Sony's pgs lineup and a PT easter egg
in middle gear solid 5 that is
everything I have for you today be sure
let me know what you cared about and I
will catch you tomorrow
you